it's become a symbol of the crackdown on
russian money the first super yacht to
be detained in uk waters the fee has now
sat in london's canary wharf for more
than two months
either good afternoon welcome to faith
but the ship's captain says it's being
held unfairly the victim of a government
pr stunt
at the time we were detained we were the
only boat here
it was easy pickings
easy pickings done for social media it's
headline grabbing click bait attention
seeking
what you see here is actually the floor
of the pool
one press of a button and that goes down
as well as the disappearing pool it has
a cinema and so-called infinity wine
cellar 400 bottles deep 40 million
pounds worth of luxury the captain
insists has been bought with clean money
we've got some rotating pieces of
furniture we're told the owner is a
russian businessman who made his wealth
in civil engineering
none of that information links the owner
of the boat
to any position in in russian politics
to to mr putin or any other political
aspiration
and you believe that i do i've known him
for 11 years
the detention order names the owner as
sergey naomenko he's not on any
sanctions list but legally speaking that
doesn't matter a connection to russia is
enough for the yacht to be held
but the government claims there's more
to it posing for photos back in march
the transport secretary said the yacht
belonged to a putin crony who's hiding
behind a complex paper trail the boat's
registered to accompany instant kits and
nevis and carries the maltese flag
it's a perfectly normal structure and
within that structure mr naumenko is
referred to as the ultimate beneficial
owner so that is all perfectly open so
there's no nefarious background to this
it is
in my world bog standard practice
at 58 meters long this is actually
considered small by super yacht
standards some are over a hundred meters
in length but when it comes to applying
sanctions against russia the government
clearly sees this as a prize catch the
department for transport said we stand
firmly by our decision to detain assets
such as the fee which satisfy both the
scope and purpose of sanctions the
secretary of state will continue to act
within his available powers to ratchet
up the economic pressure on russia
as the yacht's detained and not seized
the owner is liable for the 10 000
pounds a month mooring fees a drop in
the ocean for him perhaps but one he
doesn't think he should pay iva bennett
sky news